from software's games have always had a
somewhat niche audience but with the
release of eldon ring the size of that
audience seems to have exploded it turns
out the soulsborne formula works
exceedingly well when applied to the
template for open world games in fact
you could argue that it's exploring a
strange and enormous world rather than
the usual soul style difficulty and
mechanics that makes elden ring so much
fun the open world genre is pretty
expansive and as with major winners
before it like ubisoft's assassin's
creed games or nintendo's the legend of
zelda breath of the wild eldon ring is
sure to leave a mark on the field the
question is what should the rest of the
open world genre learn from eldon ring
though there's a lot to like about eldon
ring as well as a few things to be
annoyed with there's one element that
developers of other open world games
should take note of and use liberally
because it alters the entire feel and
scope of these games and that is the
field boss
field bosses in elden ring are bosses
you run into while you're just wandering
in the world outside of dungeons they're
bosses but you know out in the field
they're not necessarily a major change
to open world design games like horizon
forbidden west have huge monster robot
creatures like the thunder jaw or the
tremor tusk just wandering around and
you might even get a similar boss fight
scenario in breath of the wild with its
tough lynel enemies scattered throughout
its world the difference is in how eldon
ring handles these encounters how many
of them there are and what they mean for
the world at large in a lot of open
world games the actual game is all about
destinations especially with the rise of
the ubisoft model following the
popularity of titles such as assassin's
creed or far cry 3 you're constantly
being directed to a specific location
you might pass something interesting and
distracting a hot or a statue or a
treasure chest along the way but the
majority of the time the interesting
gameplay is still about the place you're
going to
part of what makes elden ring so
resonant with players is the lack of
direction as to where you need to go
making many paths equally viable
quests and important goals are only
gestured to in vague terms either by
characters or by the grace that points
you through the game you can follow
these grace trails toward a quest goal
or rather some boss you have to kill but
you still only have a generalized sense
of where you're going and no way of
really knowing how to get there the game
puts a premium on exploration which
makes it feel more free and its world
more interesting than that of many other
open world titles still the idea that
you're not given much direction in elden
ring isn't what makes it good plenty of
open world games leave you to your own
devices but often their worlds feel
empty and it can still seem like you're
just walking a long way to get to the
fun what makes elden rings world work is
not the freedom to go anywhere or to
puzzle out pathways it's the unexpected
surprises along the way when i first
made it to the altus plateau in eldon
ring i did so by traveling through an
underground tunnel and then climbing up
scaffolds and ladders through an old
mining camp the trip culminated in a
boss fight before i emerged in the new
area it was a cool trip but ultimately a
somewhat usual dungeon adventure that
made sense as a transition to a new
section of the game as i started to ride
up the hill toward the plateau proper
however the really exciting thing
happened a massive dragon swooped down
ahead of me and landed in my path
spraying the land with ludicrous orange
lightning strikes and soon realizing i
couldn't win i jumped on torrent and
galloped the hell out of there
desperately trying to avoid bolts
landing on the road around me white
knuckling my way up the road in hopes of
escaping with my life and my rooms that
experience is what makes elden ring work
so well you might have a destination in
mind when you set out across the shallow
lakes of lyernia or the rolling diseased
fields of caled but you don't know what
you're going to run into along the way
and that's not just in the sense of a
game like the elder scrolls 5 skyrim
when a fortress or a cave might distract
you and lead you to something you didn't
expect some huge creature might leap
down from a cliff or swoop in from the
coast or rise from the graveyard beneath
your feet and you never really know when
to expect it because of this the journey
to wherever you're going is just as
important as the place you're trying to
go field bosses pop up as obstacles
suddenly dropping you into tough fights
you might not have expected and
drastically changing the dynamic of an
area simply by existing think of the
tree sentinel the mounted golden knight
patrolling right next to the very first
sight of grace you encounter after
leaving the game's tutorial you wander
toward this guy and he wrecks you
straight away you immediately learn a
lesson the very land is hostile you
might not be able to face down every
threat immediately and you'll need to
find ways around them and to beat them
the tree sentinel's gravity alters the
entire area forcing you to take new
paths to watch his movements to commit
to a tough battle or to find ways to
avoid one these fights also feel
fundamentally different from just
running into something huge and scary in
the world tyrannosaurus like terra jaws
and horizon are frightening but when you
happen across one there's no real need
to engage with it if you want the
special crafting items the dinosaurs
drop you might fight it but for the most
part you're just going to avoid those
encounters as they're time consuming and
difficult and distract from your actual
goal when you see a terror jaw wandering
an area you go around but even if you do
attack it the fight isn't especially
different from engaging any other of
horizon's other robot dinosaurs in the
wild this robot dinosaur is just bigger
and takes longer to kill contrast that
with a field boss in eldon ring when you
run into one of these bosses the game
treats it like any other boss fight a
huge life bar appears on the screen and
the music changes dramatically the game
indicates that this is an event this
isn't just a run-of-the-mill monster
enemy it has the same weight as any boss
you encounter by going through a fog
gate it also indicates that these fights
are worth taking on despite being
optional and posing a frightening
challenge the change in presentation
indicates that this is a big deal and
the way elden ring handles bosses also
lets you know that this fight will be
worth it one of the early field bosses
in limgrave is the knights cavalry a
member of a group of horseback knights
that only appear when it's dark out like
the tree sentinel taking it on is tough
but your reward is the boss's excellent
flail a weapon you may well use for the
rest of the game taking on the knights
cavalry is optional and you can avoid it
if you don't think you're up to the
challenge or never discover it was there
at all but the boss showing up on your
journey fundamentally changes it no
matter what you might have been heading
for castle mourn to complete a story
quest but the story of how you got there
and what you faced becomes just as
important as what you found when you
arrived field bosses are an
encapsulation of what makes eldon rings
open world stand apart from similar
games even the most similar games like
breath of the wild while that game
engenders a lot of the same feelings of
elden ring especially in the freedom
created by allowing you to just survey
the world and find interesting things to
travel to and investigate what you
discover doesn't always feel rewarding
you might make your way to the top of a
mountain to check out some weird statues
you spotted from miles away
but that doesn't guarantee there will be
anything more to see when you arrive
with elden ring the chances are good
that even if there's little waiting for
you at the strange spot you decided to
check out the trip will have been worth
it for what you discover and fight and
kill on your way there
the way elden ring deals with field
bosses embodies a design ethos that
makes the world of elden ring feel like
it matters
as if it's big for a reason and hasn't
been made expansive just to put space
between locations the freedom to explore
is paid off by gameplay you discover
along the way in the form of boss fights
and rewards that make taking on that
gameplay worth it rather than something
you're likely to skip past on the way to
something better in elden ring field
bosses make it feel like the whole world
is important and not just the places
that the game wants you to go they make
the journey as meaningful as the
destination and that's a feeling every
open world game should strive to create
[Music]